SPEAKER 1: Now, if you're
going to have consent, that's
a very radical thing to think.
The King of England
didn't think that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
What is consent, and why?
SPEAKER 2: It's kind of more
or less a social contract,
that both parties are agreeing
to the terms and conditions.
We as the people
being governed are
allowing those who are in
power to look over and provide
the necessary
security so we can,
as they put, to
pursue our happiness.
SPEAKER 1: We might stick
with just something direct,
and simple, and understandable.
Like, if we're
equal, you wouldn't
have the authority
to do something
to me unless I say so.
Whereas the king answered the
Declaration of Independence--
did you know that?
He gave an address from the
throne, and he gave an answer.
And he basically said in there,
I was born to be the king here,
and you were born
to be the subjects.
And I am required to look
after you, and be good to you,
and take care of you, and to do
what's in your interest, what's
good for you.
But you are required
to do what I say.
And he thought that would
turn the whole thing around.
And at the moment that
he distributed this thing
across the lines to
the Continental Army,
it was melting away because
their enlistments were up.
And they read that thing
and they went, what?
Is that what he thinks?
We're staying.
We're going to do
this thing, right?
The king's idea is that I
was born with an obligation,
that you were born
with an obligation.
We both have to do our thing,
and we're born that way.
And the Declaration of
Independence denies that.
It says, we're all born equal.
So that's what they say.
And if it's like
that, then you get
to be our king if we say so.
There's a really great
document that we're not
reading in this course,
but I encourage everyone
to read it in our
Constitution reader.
It's written by Thomas
Jefferson, who, of course, was
a very powerful writer--
Earth-shakingly powerful
writer, wrote the Declaration
of Independence.
And it's called A Summary View
of the Rights of British North
America.
And in there, he goes on and
on and on, and he explains,
you get to be the
king if we say so.
You have to do what we say.
In the last paragraph,
which I'll paraphrase,
he says let those
flatter who fear.
It is not an American art.
Your counselors are partisans,
not drawn from us, right?
So he's telling
the king what for.
And it gives rise soon--
the flag with the snake
that says Don't Tread On Me.
We have a right.
We are born the same as you.
You get your carriage,
since you got it already.
It's just that you don't get
to tell us what to do from it.
Consent is born in equality
in that way, right?
And you just have to
remember that we Americans,
we just breathe that from birth.
We get that with mother's milk.
That's what we think.
We think we're born equal.
It's the reason why we
think we can do whatever
we want if we work hard enough.
It's the reason I thought--
my dad's a schoolteacher
from Pocahontas, Arkansas--
but I didn't know that wasn't
the grandest thing in the world
to be.
I knew we weren't
rich, but I didn't
think anybody was born
better than I, nor I better
than anybody else.
Churchill used to love to
say about equality, he'd say,
it's the principle
that everybody
is as good as everybody
else, or a little better.
[LAUGHTER]
You like that?
Churchill was very witty.
So now, if you're
going to have consent,
that's a very radical
thing to think.
The King of England
didn't think that, right?
The fact that he gave that
address from the throne
and had it distributed--
he thought that
would be persuasive.
Later, they send Ben
Franklin, who was, let's say,
a very artful human being.
We all know what
that means, right?
[LAUGHTER]
For example, he was the
world's greatest spokesman
for pious middle class morality.
Anyway, they sent him
to England to negotiate.
He didn't get on well.
They liked him better in Paris.
He went there, too.
And he gets over there and
he talks with the cabinet.
And the cabinet says, we
are the mother country,
and you are the children.
And you must do what we say.
And he writes a letter back
to the Continental Congress
and says, there's
going to be a war.
[LAUGHTER]
Because what they think--
and remember, what they think
is what everybody thinks.
It's what the King of
France thinks, who later
subsidized our revolution.
It's what they all think.
It's what the world has
thought from time immemorial.
And these guys don't think that.
That's a remarkable
development in human history.
SPEAKER 3: Thank
you for watching.
We hope you're enjoying
our Highlights series
and invite you to explore
all of Hillsdale College's
online courses.
They are free and for
everyone who loves to learn.